so some of you may have noticed it's
been a little while since I uploaded a
video here on numberphile and I thought
it might be fun to explain why basically
I've been away I've been in Canada and
in the US for two events a conference
called brain stem and the big VidCon
conference in Anaheim in California
while I was at those events I had the
opportunity to meet some of the big
players of YouTube science including
vihart who I know a lot of you watch
already no issue of 100 million to 141
million Henry from minutephysics all in
one equation and it's humbly called the
standard model Destin from smarter every
day hey it's me Destin welcome to
smarter every day and today we're gonna
show you some pretty cool high-speed
Derek from veritasium the first thing I
need to do is talk about vectors Michael
from Vsauce hey Vsauce Michael here and
the mysterious CGP grey human islands
the Turks and Caicos Islands Gibraltar
the British Virgin Islands Akrotiri and
Dhekelia Anguilla I didn't only mate
them I also had a chance to film a few
quick interviews with them and I'll be
uploading them soon worried Brady
probably on my channel sixty symbols so
keep an eye out for that there's already
the interview with Henry from
minutephysics there I'll read it aloud
while I'm writing it so I can hear what
it sounds like and then once it's once
it's done I'll print it off and bring it
in here and record it now while we're at
VidCon Destin from smarter every day
brought along his phantom high-speed
camera which is great fun we set it up
in the main hall here's me about to be
slapped in the face
and that's a slap from two of the most
famous hands on YouTube that's
minutephysics and via heart what a
privilege that was now had a great time
there's lots to talk about from lots of
photos and links and I've put them all
in the video description under this
video so please do have a look and I
hope to see all those people again soon
although it won't be too soon because I
actually just put my passport through
the washing machine so uh I think I need
to send off for another one
but there'll be another normal
numberphile video very soon then you
list the third diagonal then you take
the fourth diagonal and the fifth so
eventually you are going to list every
fraction every faction appears on a
diagonal and you're going to list them